this is something that i shouldn't say
but i'm going to say it because it needs
to be said
how are the people who block school
choice any different than george wallace
when he stood at the door and banned
blacks
from attending the university
how is it any different
[Music]
that's right can you believe it i'm
still here living inside this tent for
100 days from november 20th to february
28th bringing to you the awareness that
you need to know
about the violence on the south side of
chicago and trying to raise as much
money as we possibly can on this block
called o block where a community center
is really needed it's called o block
because it's named after a young man
named od perry who was shot and killed
the gangs took the o in his name and
started calling it o block well we
decided
we want to keep the o but we're going to
call it opportunity block
i want to thank fox for giving me this
opportunity for bringing you every day
and every evening rooftop revelations
where i share with you my thoughts
my viewpoints my opinions tonight i want
to talk to you about something that has
been on my mind for years
school choice
i'm a true believer in school choice our
kids should not have to attend the local
school which is absolutely failing our
kids just because they were born in the
wrong zip code
just to give you an idea of how bad it
is
there's an elementary school which is
only two blocks away from where i sit on
this rooftop
now i'm not one to bad mouth folks or
talk
ill about individuals especially school
teachers i support and love teachers
i believe good teachers are the best
hope for our kids
but we must have some accountability
here
there are about 700 kids that attend
this elementary school
there's a teacher one teacher for every
21 kids
100 percent of these kids are
economically disadvantaged according to
the school standards
now here's the hard truth
only four percent of the students are
proficient in math
for reading only six percent of the kids
are proficient
in reading this means that 96 of the
kids are not proficient in math and 94
are not proficient in reading
let that sink in
that means that nearly all the kids are
behind and it's only
elementary school that i'm talking about
how is this acceptable in america one of
the richest countries in
the world and this is the year 2022 what
chance do our kids have in this
neighborhood we're failing them in every
way our government
local state and federal they know this
is happening yet they do nothing about
it
worse they block our efforts to pursue
one of the biggest civil rights issue of
our time
school choice
how can they in good conscience tell
parents that they must send their kids
to a failing school yet they do it year
after year i know
this is something that i shouldn't say
but i'm going to say it because it needs
to be said
how are the people who block school
choice any different than george wallace
when he stood at the door and banned
blacks
from attending the university
how is it any different
kids especially poor black kids are
being denied their right to a good and
free public education
this issue has bothered me for so long
the kids that attend the local
elementary are my kids
and i have long wanted to open a charter
school within my project good community
center as a way to offer parents and
their kids a choice in their education
i believe school choice is one of the
best expressions of free market
capitalism
one of the best expressions that we have
today
especially because it gives power to
those who come from lesser means
this empowers them
we should not have bad schools being
propped up by the union we need to
empower parents so that they may choose
the best education for their child
the reason why i never announced it is
because our city has a moratorium
against charter schools
i never announced my plans for such a
charter school because i feared it may
never become a reality
but i decided to tell you my
long-standing plans tonight because i
feel that i owe it to you
to be fully transparent about all my
goals for this community center
even if they may not come to fruition
and that goal of opening a charter
school is one that we must accomplish is
one that we must fight for
we are in a local and national crisis
right now and i've seen how successful
charter schools can send off children to
better lives opening a charter school
has and will always be one of our goals
for this community
and i know
we will make that into a reality
it won't be easy the political powers
are strong but with our neighborhood
school where 96 of the kids are not
proficient in math and 94 are not
proficient in reading we have no choice
i know we can do better than that far
better
we will
and i will
fight until we win the battle
of free
school
choice
you